while hundreds of thousands refugees
coming to Germany do pose a challenge
for the country many economists believe
the influx also represents a great
opportunity some even argue that the new
migrants will help boost economic growth
well to talk more about this I'm joined
by the head of the Munich Institute for
economic research the FO Hans von Essen
thank you so much for joining us here in
Germany
we do have many many apprenticeship
positions that remain unfilled there
seem to be a lack of young people who
are in a position to take on these
apprenticeships could motivated refugees
fill that gap yes in principle but we
are talking about its completely
different numbers we have twenty thirty
thousand open positions for
apprenticeship while in the month of
September alone it is expected that
270,000 refugees came so this is a
completely different dimension the
refugees will cost a lot of money for
the time being they come as asylum
seekers it's not an economic issue it is
a humanitarian act but with Germany's
aging population and a fairly low
birthrate aren't these refugees perhaps
the answer to saving the German welfare
system the pension system no they will
cost a lot of money for a month a
refugee costs between 1000 and 1200
euros and it takes years to integrate
them into the labor market which we have
to try of course then in the long run
their children indeed may make a
positive contribution in their terms but
it is wrong to see it this way there is
war people are fleeing the war they look
for asylum in Germany is opening the
gates in order to give them asylum and
check whether they are applicants who
are have the right to get asylum so I
hope that other countries would do the
same thing rather than insisting on
Germany carrying all the burden
well if the reality is in fact that
there are people fleeing war and as a
humanitarian country it is Germany's
obligation to allow these people to come
here so what will it take to ensure that
these people have the best chance of
becoming integrated both in German
society and in the workforce
what do they need they need education
they have to learn the language they
have to learn Latin writing many cannot
read and write actually the education
quality of the immigrants is rather low
so they immigrate into the lower end of
the labor market and they will put
pressure on wages which is a major
problem for the unions Germany just
introduced a minimum wage so that
obviously conflicts with the immigration
of less skilled people Oh we'll have to
wait and see what happens and hope for
the best has been a villain thank you so
much for talking to us I'm made in
Germany you're welcome